hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar measuring cortisol in
clinical settings pitfalls challenges
and promises I am Judy or are
collaborates and I'll be moderating this
session today's educational web seminar
is presented by lab routes the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
is made possible by an open educational
grant from agilent technologies agilent
technologies has said no input in the
selection of speakers content or mode of
presentation let's get started you can
pose questions to the speaker during the
presentation while they're fresh in your
mind to do so simply type them into the
drop-down box located on the far left of
your screen labeled
ask a question and click on the send
button questions will be answered after
the presentation to enlarge the slide
window click on the arrows at the top
right hand corner of the presentation
window if you experience technical
problems seeing or hearing the
presentation just click on the support
tab found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by typing it into the answer a
question box located on the far left of
your screen this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process of
obtaining your credits I now present
today speaker li Shang Chen PhD dr. Chen
has more than 10 years of experience
directing and managing clinical
laboratories in the academic center
industry and in government regulatory
agencies most recently she served as the
division director of chemistry and
toxicology for the Bureau of
laboratories within Michigan's state
government previously she served as
associate director of the automated
laboratory at the University of
Rochester Medical Center as a staff
fellow at the FDA and as laboratory
director for Firefly Diagnostics startup
dr. Chen obtained a PhD in nutritional
biochemistry from the universe
the of California at Berkeley and
completed two postdoctoral fellowships
at the University of California Davis
and Mayo Clinic respectively her
complete bio is found on the lab roots
website
dr. Chen will now begin her presentation
thank you very much bye duties kind
introduction there are three learning
objectives for my today's presentation
so after completing this webinar you
will be able to first describe the
different specimen types and their
clinical utilities or chorus of
management secondly you will be able to
describe the methodologies and ACA
performances of current Carrizo
immunoassays and LC tented mass spec
matters for holy so measurement in the
conquer laboratories you will also be
able to know the recent advances and the
current stages in the development of two
major types of Carrizo poonam care
devices chorus or biosensors and a
miniature mass spectrometry system
karissa is the major form of
glucocorticoids and is released in
response to stress and fasting
it controls energy metabolism with the
bad effect of increasing blood glucose
levels
karissa has posed anti-inflammatory and
immunosuppressive effects also also
involved in water and electrolyte
balance as well as controlling blood
pressure through its binding to mineral
corticoids
receptor therefore CODIS of
over-production
or deficiency can significantly affect
our health and wealth be nurturing
course l is extension for the
investigation of conditions leading to
Adreno insufficiency and cola so access
especially for its Addison's disease and
Cushing's syndrome most diseases are
have announced this
like symptoms and their port relies on
appropriate coding some test Cody so
testing in order to prevent delays of
diagnosis the dynamic function testing
including eighth ETH stimulation and
text are Masson suppression tests are
most useful for assessing Adreno
function and the give definitive
diagnosis of related disorders measuring
holy soul is also useful in guiding
proper dosing of mataró pong which is a
medication used to treat Cushing's
syndrome cortisol secretion follows the
korean readlyn who is the highest peak
appears in the early morning and the
lowest stroke around midnight the
testing result from these two time
points is most important in diagnosis of
Khorasan related diseases for example in
patients with severe crucians there's
the card in reason is lost and therefore
the Carrizo label constantly remains
high only 10% of the circulating
cortisol is in three bioactive wound
while 80% of them finds her Carrizo
binding globulin CBG and the rest of 10%
is albumin and the alteration of the
alteration of the CPG and Alba me will
lead to the well lead to the change of
circulating serum cortisol and therefore
may lead to inappropriate clinical
diagnosis unlike serum albumin the
majority of the urinary and celebratory
so are three and and bad yurina cortisol
is unaffected by hepatic metabolism
therefore 24-hour urinary three quarter
cell correlate well with serum
pre-chorus though and even in the
patient with
Quarry so access them therefore its
management is implemented in the initial
diagnosis of crucians Carrizo answers
saliva through diffusion and is
independent of saliva flowing rate
salivary cortisol responds well to
change in plasma core so quickly and
reliably therefore Lenni salivary
cortisol is now recommended as the first
line screening test for Cushing's
syndrome however several cortisol is
present in a much less concentration
compared to serum host
Caruso and therefore can only be
reliably measured by the more sensitive
our seat and the mass back methods code
initial measurement has a long history
in clinical laboratories the first email
sa automated immunoassay for cortisol
was described in 1992 and since them are
the commercially available chorus of
immunoassays have been and they still
now the most commonly used method for
CODIS or measurements in clinical
laboratory but move almost all of them
to varying degrees cross-react with
other steroid metabolites chemical
structure of cortisol is shown at the
top of this figure it shares similar
structural similarity with many as
exogenous and endogenous steroid
molecules for example the commonly
prescribed prisoners law as shown in the
bottom lab has known to be cross-react
with 30 percent of the commonly used the
chorus of amino acids
moreover the upstream precursors
progesterone and eleven deoxy codicil
when present in high concentration have
been reported to affect the quarry so
measurement by amino a taste
effective patient care even know is they
are not created equal
there exists great internet variability
the lack of a single reference material
as well as the lack of a single
reference measurement method that is the
major factor accounting for the observed
intra a severe apology furthermore
there's an ongoing a they change even
from the essays made by a single vendor
for example as shown in the table on the
right
Siemens and where's Cory so si has
exhibited a parent of performance change
over a three-year period from 2010 to
2013 of these bytes there is no major
change of a say formula moreover simple
metrics affect accounts for the observe
the increase in inter a severe poverty
observed in the critical year of
patients and for those patients with
severe renal diseases recent study has
revealed that Cory saw a say variability
has impacted the interpretation of ACTH
stimulation test used for the
differential diagnosis of a trainer
insufficiency a single cutoff value of
559 or molar a derived from historic
studies have been used for all the
clinical Carrizo in oasis for
interpreting ACTH stimulation test
however in a recent study the responses
of Cora so after the ACTH stimulation
was measured by five contemporary
contemporary Imanol essays as shown in
the table here and exhibit apparent
differences when compared to GC and as
methods especially in group of females
taking oral contraceptive as shown
the right-hand column therefore the
continuing continuing use of this single
cutter and may really lead to
misdiagnosis of Adreno insufficiency it
should be replaced by validating a
specific cut out the serial measurement
of seer mechanism is also used to
optimizing the dosing regimen for
treating cushions with material on which
blocks the conversion of eleventy
exporters o tu corazon as shown in the
left-hand panel and resulted in tempo
increase of this precursor the elevation
of the oxycotin saw is known to
interfere with all the chorus or even
all aces and therefore inflated the
chorus of measurement by this method as
shown in the figure on the right when
compared with the chorus or measurement
with LC tandem mass spec methods
consequentially these main trigger in
appropriate dose escalation and the cost
harm
impatience mass spectrometric methods
offered much needed specificity and
sensitivity for chorus or measurement
the first gbms reference method was
described in 1975 but it is not until
the maturation of several key
technologies then the high throughput
record allows this of biomolecules by LC
tandem mass spec became available and
found its way in to clinical
laboratories in late nineties the first
profiling of choruses that a sterile met
steroid by tandem a spacer and the first
heist you put non-derivative LC ms/ms
method for urinary chorus or measurement
were all reported in early 2000 these
was followed by the development of many
more
ms/ms method specific for target sample
types by optimizing the ACA parameters
including sample prep mobile phase
composition chromatographic separation
and the ms/ms
transition ions now I am going to
quickly walk you through these specific
parameters for LC ms/ms Carrizo a phase
the initial sample extraction by ways of
protein precipitation liquid liquid
extraction or solid phase extraction and
at removing proteins and other
interfering substances which may affect
the chorus or ionization efficiency
protein precipitation is simple rapid
amenable to automate automation and the
relatively inexpensive and therefore is
the method of choice by many LC tandem
mass spec method use the in clinical
laboratories equilibrium dialysis gel
filtration and ultra filtration a method
available for separating serum three
cortisol from protein bound a fraction
however these methods are all
time-consuming and tedious therefore add
a say variability to the method as a
consequence there is no single robust
reference range for a serum recorder
Mughal painting methanol is the
preferred solvent because it promotes
eye information however when mixed with
waters mesmo increases its viscosity and
cause high column back pressure as the
new nitrile has lower viscosity can be
used instead but it is more expensive
it is also known that quarries or
ionization can be enhanced by the use of
buffer systems such as ammonium chloride
onion outside and the formic acid by
virtually the hydrophobicity and steric
nature a quarry so are most commonly
separated from its structural analog
spicy 18 columns several commercially
available
c18 cava columns differing in their
unhappy carbon loading capacity and the
leakin surface area coverage have been
successfully used for separating corazon
but may account for varying performances
c5 has a shorter carbon shell and
therefore allows shorter wrong time yes
i electrospray ionisation ABC i
atmospheric pressure chemical ionization
and recently atmospheric pressure photo
ionization a PPI
have all been successfully used for
ionizing Caruso and achieve detection of
quantitation below org clinical
requirements
most of the LC ms/ms method using the
clinical laboratory are ESI based
although a BCI and a PPR are more
efficient in ionizing nonpolar compounds
such as karissa transition ions used for
detects detect coração are similar
across methods most of the LC tandem
aspect massive volcanism monitor and the
363 121 transition which is the most
sensitive I am pair however it is
interfered by the presence of a high
concentration of cretinous long and its
metabolites alternatively monitoring and
ze transition
363 to 67 or mgs3 63 97 are more
selective but less sensitive these
tables summarized the representative
outs attend a mass spec method for
quantitating serum chorus though most of
methods is operating in the positive
mode few methods used ESI in active mode
mode reported enhance the
signal-to-noise ratio also several
method least here were developed for
steroid profiling by month by monitoring
multiple steroid metabolites this type
of method typically need longer run time
in order to adequately a separated
monitored steroid metabolites many
elseit and the mask pack method are also
developed for measuring urinary
cortisone diluted and shoots method with
simple sample prep step and the rapid
turnaround time was initially explored
however introducing relatively dirty
samples into the analytical system
greatly reduce colon lifespans and
require more some more instrument
clean-up and the services in an
alternative have been an alternative way
the samples are first introduced into a
turbo flow meta chromatographic system
and the turbulent solvent flows through
a short porous column where the small
molecules was separated from protein the
latter was then sized excluded and the
Scarlet
after the separation the analytical
column c18 och can be in stood before
and as MS analysis
Mona Lisa Mona Lisa color with its
porous rod system
allows high flow rates and therefore can
be used to develop more rapid methods in
addition monitoring Caruso and its
urinary metabolite and them observe the
specific metabolites ratio such as
chorus or to chorus on ratio or the
ratio between tetra hydro metabolites of
cortisol are known to be effective in
diagnosis of related these odors for
steroid synthesis and metabolism saliva
as the matrix contains pure interfering
compound it's non-invasive and cost
effective collection is appealing to
both patients and physicians
however saliva contains much higher
concentration of Cory stop there for
measuring chorus or and corazon
concurrently using tandem mass spec
methods can facilitate the test
interpretation and an expected high
ratio of chorus or to Cody song for
example indicates oral hydro chorus or
contamination
since a fete sensitivity is crucial for
measuring salivary cortisol a sample
prep step which purify and concentrate
saliva is an initial and almost all the
tendon mass spec method for salivary
cortisol monitor the most sensitive NZ
363 1:21 because tandem aspects MSL are
mostly home-brewed there exist there do
exist
sa specific variations therefore there
is no common reference ranch and disease
specific caudal valleys be meant to be
established long let me quickly
summarize what we have covered so far
first serum total cortisol results can
be me
bleeding impatient with alter the CBG or
opening concentrations second 24-hour
hearing three-quarters of and late night
salivary cortisol are recommended for
screening Cushing's syndrome third
Carrizo measurement by immunoassay due
to its problems of interference and the
great interlace a variability may lead
to improper dosing of mataira pong and
incorrect interpretation of ACTH
stimulation test therefore endocrines
Society have recommended to use our seat
anthem aspect method to replace email I
say in these two conditions
firstly metric specific LC ms/ms method
provide superior sensitivity and
specificity
however they say standardization is poor
and the validation of reference ranges
and cutoff values of dynamic testings we
meant to be done in the second part of
my presentation we will discuss codasyl
analysis at point of care
point of care POC devices are portable
easy to use devices which can provide a
rapid result outside the traditional
clinical settings there are two major
types of POC devices the first type is
the handheld device with miniature
detection system and disposable
cartridges or sample concentration and
separation the second type are bench top
analyzers similar to the ones used in
the central laboratories but are smaller
and less complex well why do we need
point-of-care on Quora so testing first
coryza spikes 15 minutes after the onset
of a stressor therefore are used as by
martyr of stress adaptation in response
to environmental and the behavioural
triggers controlled by the HPA axis
second three second early in clinical
settings timely results also extension
for intra procedural chorus of
monitoring for adrenal been sampling
adrenaline sampling is the go standard
procedures used for distinguishing
between the surgical incurable
unilateral ad astra unilateral attached
on producing adenoma drawn the
medication responsive bilateral
idiopathic hypo attached realism as
shown in the figure on the Left
adrenaline sampling use image guided
catheterization to obtain blood samples
from both right and left adrenaline as
well as inferior vena cava as indicated
by the red and purple arrows in the
beaver then the quarry cell then the
ratio of Kony's the label in the in each
adrenaline vampers such the level in
inferior vena cava with first used to
determine the success of the procedure
subsequently the ratio of Korus or
normalized at a strong level between
right and left adrenal van known as
lateral index is used to determine the
type of primary hyperaldosteronism and
the subsequent appropriate treatments of
modality radicalism a phase were
developed to operate under tabletop
analyzers such as the one shown in the
figure on the left which can be used in
or near the radiation suite however
operator competency and the instrument
mental map maintenance
problematic recently a quick easy to use
lateral flow essay has been developed
for this purpose but the video color
reading only provided mi quantitative
results therefore both type of method
peels the masses are not quite least
rush examples to the central laboratory
for testing is still the standard
practice for adrenaline sampling codasyl
biosensors were initially developed
developed for the field investigation of
coração as a stress biomarker but recent
technical advances in this bill has
greatly improved about the ability of
these biosensors for accurately
quantitative corazon with the great
potential to translate into the clinical
is at PLC settings here we are going to
discuss three types of novel Corozal
biosensors they are lateral flow as a
face the smart phone system and hi Cori
so antibody face the Imanol sensors and
the Optima base the chorus of biosensors
natural flow immunoassay RFA is the most
common used POC format with easy to use
fast and low-cost features but like the
specificity and sensitivity of the
clinical laboratory use the CODIS Oasis
recently lateral flow in Eurasia was
integrated into smartphone system and
helping is CCD camera and optical erase
as photo detectors to create a new
category of POC devices an example of
such innovation is I shall kill as shown
in the figure a
in the upper left which consists of a
smartphone a test reading biosensors a
disposable LF a test cassette and a
mobile app for test interpretation light
scattering was used as the detection
modality which was optimal empirically
optimized the during eye and in stage so
that the desire a light scattering from
gold nanoparticles has been greatly
improved this device claims a limit of
detection and linear wrench well enough
to analyze the late night salivary
cortisol and only required less than 10
minutes first time from sampling to test
resulting in fact I help you is now
commercially available and have been
used to appeals it plz testing in low
source settings electrochemical immuno
sensors is based on the principle of
measuring the changes in electrical
properties induced by electro active by
electro active redox change due to the
absorption of and analytes
unto the electrode surface
functionalized with antibodies as shown
in this bigger the resulting redox
potential change was then detected by
either the enzyme linked secondary
antibody as shown in Figure a in the
bottom panel or by label-free redox
probe in Figure B label-free biosensors
on has the advantages of in evening
preparation low-cost mass production and
higher sensitivity and therefore are
preferred a safe formats
this figure shows new automatic micro
fluidic system integrated with
electrochemical corazon
most answers as shown in the upper panel
of this figure and high chorus of
antibodies were immobilized unto the
disposable gold micro electrodes which
were embedded in the Asics chamber of
micro fluidic manifold as shown in the
right and then electrical responses is
measured by using cyclic voltammetry by
interfacing with a miniature potential
shift connected to micro controller as
shown in the lower panel the reloading
device is ultra sensitive has a
five-block linear wrench but will
require 30 minutes to come complete the
entire reaction the high surface area of
nano material provide much more binding
site and therefore I greatly increase
the antibody loading capacity also
decrease the charge transfer resistance
of the resulting device as shown in the
cartoon on the upper panel by using the
zinc oxide nano flakes or nanorod as the
immobilization matrix the Nano device
has exhibit equivalently excellent
analytical performance as its bulk
material counterpart but over much
higher chemical stability higher
catalytic activity as well as
biocompatibility but as we all know
antibodies are prone to denaturation and
batch to batch variations which restrict
the wide application of chorus of immuno
sensors optimist our single-stranded DNA
or RNA usually 20 to 80 nucleotides in
length and can be attended by define the
selection process so that they have high
energy and the specificity against
target analytes Optimus has advantages
of denaturation resistance long
shock-like and the lethal batch to batch
variability for Carrizo sensei as shown
in the lower panel but these placement
they was designed so that the optimal
loaded nanoparticles are first occupied
by structural analog triamcinolone ta
for short
when sample is applied to the device
corridor in the sample displaces ta from
the Abner's the release the ta is then
electro chemically reduced greatly
modified electrodes and they give
signals for chorus or computation such a
device when used the nano material has
reported an excellent sensitivity a wide
linear range and an impressive short
reaction time of 2.5 minutes
unfortunately interference was noted at
the lower chorus or reference wrench in
the presence of high progesterone
concentration nevertheless after nama
based the chorus of our sensors with
modification and improvement as told
appropriate potential for using in the
POC clinical settings in the near future
ambient ionization and the
miniaturization of mass spectrometers
are two separate research fields that
have been advanced rapidly in the last
decade the integrated ambient ionization
miniature ms system represents a major
research and the development direction
of future
MS instrumentation suitable whole point
of care clinical applications ambient
ionization
refers to direct that organizational
analytes from the road samples in their
ambien states without sample extraction
or purification among many ambien
ionization method already described so
far paper spray ionization is the most
developed for quantitating small
analytes from complex mattresses as
shown in the figure on the tablet
samples along to a paper triangle when
it was the appropriate solvent and a
high voltage is then applied to the
paper she produced gas based iron for MS
analysis extraction spray as shown in
the lower left is an improved version of
paper spray the paper substrate is
inserted into a capillary emitter
cartridges made for the ease of mass
production and for the compatibility to
interface with more types of mass
spectrometers hence paper spread
ionization that shield most success in
drug please
testing the example shown in the figure
on the right determined simultaneously 8
illicit drugs with only a MicroBot
within 90 seconds next slide
slug flow Michel extraction nano ESI is
developed for direct ionization from
liquid samples a disposable capillary
was a pool of the chip was used to
perform the entire sampling and
ionization process as shown in the meter
of beaker a then to liquid plaques are
formed by sequentially in Jeff 5 micro
liter of organic solvent and sample
earring of blood into capillary
subsequently by a simple a tilting the
capillary five times
the internal circulation 45 each wad and
that facilitate the transfer of analyzed
to and away from the liquid liquid
interface and therefore greatly increase
the extraction efficiency after the
extraction as shown in the figure be a
stainless steel wire then deserted to
reach the organic solvent flat and a
high voltage is applied to generate Nano
a TSI for MS analysis slug flow micro
extraction nano ESI have achieved that
successful performance in many
toxicology testing however ionization
efficiency by nano ESI is not great for
nonpolar sterile molecules to address
this problem as shown in Figure a on the
right an additional illegally part of 5
micro liter of water containing hydroxyl
amine is inserted between the sample
rock and the organic solvent plot2d
derivatized a steroid molecules this
modification greatly improved the
signal-to-noise ratio of the derivatives
the steroid molecules as you can see
from the spectra in vigor see compared
to thicker be in order to be light and
portable the miniature MS system is
designed with reduced size the pumping
system the resulting decrease in pumping
capacity led to the high background
noise and loss of sensitivity
fortunately the development of
discontinuous atmospheric pressure
introduction there in technique allows
for post
ion introduction which greatly decreased
the demand of pumping capacity and still
allow adequate
of ions being transferred into ion trap
mass analyzers for ms/ms
analysis a deadly equipped meaning 12ms
system the latest version in the series
as shown in the figures on upper panel
claims a limit of detection within 10 x
differences from the sophisticated lab
scale ms instrument therefore many
progresses have been made but more
challenges are there to be overcome
before the miniature ms system can be
used the impiously clinical settings
first due to engineering difficulty only
view ambient ionization method has been
adapted to miniature ms system and
there's the old room for improvement in
ionization efficiency of the system on
the other hand the disposable sample
cartridges which are essential for easy
assemble introduction to plc devices
were developed for paper spread and slug
flow micro extraction method as we
discussed earlier but the biggest
challenge of all is to achieve an
adequate performance mandatory by
clinical applications so far the method
for properly incorporating internal
standard into samples have been achieved
and which can enhance the quantitation
precision but interference is still a
big issue due to limited chromatography
the possible solution include the use of
stable isotope labeled internal
standards and most importantly target
analyte specific optimizations need to
be carried out during a development and
subsequent implementation stages
lastly significant effort is needed
to improve the rapport disability of
data generated by miniature MS system
especially when it was used out in
materials the real-time calibration is
one of the possible solution so in
summary we have discussed the recent
advances in the technical development
for three types of POC corazon devices
the first is the LF a natural flow is a
linked smartphone system which is
current currently commercially available
and is applied to the source limiting
settings the second type is the
label-free biosensors when used with
micro fluidic system together with the
nanotechnology have great potential for
real-time codasyl monitoring the third
type is the ambient ionization miniature
ms system although many challenges it's
still there to be overcome it will allow
the red chemical analysis of unmodified
samples in a streamlined procedure
therefore holds the promise of white
clinical application at point care in
the future this concludes my
presentation today thank you very much
for your attention thank you dr. Chynn
for your presentation a quick reminder
for our audience on how to submit
questions simply type them into the drop
down box located on the far left of your
presentation window labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
dr. Chen will answer as many questions
as time permits what measures have been
or should be taken by clinical
laboratory communities at this moment to
minimize the assay variations this is
the good question I think innovation is
no small undertaking it requires
national and international efforts and
collaboration but the good proficiency
testing programs already played an
important role in reducing variability
of testing result among the
participating laboratories the
successful approaches has been taken by
PT programs such as the UK's vitamin-d
external Quality assessment scheme
Decker's CDs these hormones
generalization program and other C appt
programs to improve fa agreement and
recently accuracy for example by simply
using media instead of a laboratory
trimming can minimize the effect of our
outliers and also for a PHA accuracy a
more and more teaching programs are
using the definitive methods either GCMs
or the LC tandem mass spec as the
standard and the calculated deviations
of all the other methods this measure
could identify the a-site reached a more
easily and does include overall as a
accuracy since metric effect is the big
issue for steroid measurement it is
important first to use the control made
in appropriate metrics with target
values assigned by reference measurement
procedures to ensure the traceability to
the primary reference material and OSA
it is recently advocated to participate
in so-called accuracy based the PT
program if they exist they exist which
used the minimum process the human
samples to avoid a matrix effect of the
PT material what would be the criteria
used to judge the performance adequacy
of a POC cortisol devices this is a very
good
question but hard to give a very good
answer and my short answer is it depends
on the intended use quarry so
point-of-care testing is most likely to
use the for initial screen of true
Shenzhen central and in such a situation
a sensitivity capable of detect the
match of midnight celebrate 3/4 so
taking the priority seat if used for
ruling throughout the Adreno hyper hyper
function then accuracy around and define
a cut-off balance is also very important
and also robustness to give consistent
result in various environments where the
tests are performed is desirable in
addition ease of use fast turnaround
time and the small sample balling good
features for good VOD devices well I
would like to once again thank dr. Chen
for her presentation do you have any
final comments knowing thank you well
thanks again I'd also like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we do not have time for today
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration we would like to
thank our educational sponsor Agilent
for today's educational webcast this
webcast can be viewed on-demand through
September 2018 lab routes will alert you
via email when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye